[Music]
for the microscopic labrum c.elegans
life equates to just a few short weeks
on earth compare that with the tortoise
which can age to more than 100 years
mice and rats reach the end of their
lives after just four years while for
the bowhead whale earth's longest lived
mammal death can come after 200 like
most living things the vast majority of
animals gradually degenerate after
reaching sexual maturity in the process
known as aging but what does it really
mean to age the drivers behind this
process are varied and complicated but
aging is ultimately caused by cell death
and dysfunction when we're young we
constantly regenerate cells in order to
replace dead and dying ones but as we
age this process slows down
in addition older cells don't perform
their functions as well as young ones
that makes our bodies go into a decline
which eventually results in disease and
death but if that's consistently true
why the huge variance in aging patterns
and lifespan within the animal kingdom
the answer lies in several factors
including environment and body size
these can place powerful evolutionary
pressures on animals to adapt which in
turn makes the aging process different
across species consider the cold depths
of the Atlantic and Arctic seas where
Greenland sharks can live to over 400
years in the Arctic clam known as the
Quahog can live up to 500 perhaps the
most impressive of these ocean-dwelling
ancients is the Antarctic glass sponge
which can survive over 10,000 years in
frigid waters in cold environments like
these heart beats and metabolic rates
slow down researchers theorized that
this also causes a slowing of the aging
process in this way the environment
shapes longevity
when it comes to size it's often but not
always the case that larger species have
a longer lifespan than smaller ones for
instance an elephant or whale will live
much longer than a mouse rat or vole
which in turn have years on flies and
worms some small animals like worms and
flies are also limited by the mechanics
of their cell division they're mostly
made up of cells that can't divide and
be replaced when damaged so their bodies
expire more quickly and size is a
powerful evolutionary driver in animals
smaller creatures are more prone to
predators a mouse for instance can
hardly expect to survive more than a
year in the wild so it is evolved to
grow and reproduce more rapidly like an
evolutionary defense mechanism against
its shorter lifespan larger animals by
contrast are better at fending off
predators and so they have the luxury of
time to grow to large sizes and
reproduce multiple times during their
lives exceptions to the size rule
include bats birds moles and turtles but
in each case these animals have other
adaptations that allow them to escape
predators but there are still cases
where animals with similar defining
features like size and habitat age at
completely different rates in these
cases genetic differences like how each
organism cells respond to threats often
account for the discrepancies in
longevity so it's the combination of all
these factors playing out to differing
degrees in different animals that
explains the variability we see in the
animal kingdom so what about us humans
currently have an average life
expectancy of 71 years meaning that
we're not even close to being the
longest living inhabitants on earth but
we are very good at increasing our life
expectancy in the early 1900's humans
only lived an average of 50 years
since then we've learned to adapt by
managing many of the factors that cause
deaths like environmental exposure and
nutrition this and other increases in
life expectancy make us possibly the
only species on earth to take control
over our natural fate
[Music]
you